so look i picked this right off against
the rams
this is what you were made for man this
is your route
[Music]
show them how to do it marcus peters
[Music]
ah left go here and it is underrated
time
where we take damn good nfl players and
show you areas where they're
surprisingly great
kind of like the surprisingly great
rates of state farm
yeah you betcha today we're focusing on
my main man marcus peters of the
baltimore ravens who i think
is always been underrated on the plug
i'm getting madden on the phone
it's time to get those ratings up yo
jake
call madden let's figure this out
calling madden ratings adjuster well
look who it is
clint oldenburg how you doing clint hey
i'm
i'm good good to see you again marcus
peters
this guy he jumps routes he covers but i
got two interesting categories okay
okay all right let's call him up my
favorite corner in the nfl
jake call my guy marcus peters
calling marcus peters
and there he is the big baller shot
caller nobody better
marcus peters marcus this is clint he is
the madden ratings adjuster say what's
up what's up with it man that's why you
so cool dog
listen i already spoke to the folks at
ea
and if we could impress clint with your
catching ability
they're gonna consider bumping you up to
possibly the number one
catch rated corner in the game for sure
hey man i appreciate that too
clint are there certain drills that you
think would
be great for corners to test catch we'd
really want to see is more like wide
receiver type drills like catch
difficulty
can you not see the ball all the way can
you react to it very quickly
uh just some of those ball skills you
don't see very often from dbs
okay okay okay we gonna do something
there's another rating i want to tackle
first
take a look at kick accuracy it is so
low
clint how can i test this wow uh all
right that's an interesting one we don't
get this one very often but i guess
if you can test him in placement check
his accuracy
on punting might be some room for
improvement i do this
we talking about the dustin cope wits
dropping it in the corner
type of plan you feel me okay
well if you're feeling confident let's
put you to the test man
let's do it all right we'll be waiting
okay clint i appreciate you
all right so check this out we're going
to go after your kick accuracy rating
with a
coffin corner punt challenge if you
notice marcus we placed three
semicircles just in front of the end
zone
you hit the smallest innermost circle
that's worth five points
the middle is three the large outer one
is worth two
you're going to get five attempts and
every punt your total goes up by that
amount
and as long as you're within 10 yards of
that outermost circle
your rating stays the same we can
improve your kick accuracy rating by
25 points today if all five hit
within that inner semicircle oh yeah
that's the easy money that's the easy
one i'll tell you
dustin cope with him vows phone girl
i'll do this
well all right let's go ah let's go here
they go we got
wasting no time
i got some points that's two
[Music]
oh so we got probably about three my man
looking like
marcus colquitt out here i love dustin
copeland but
if anything i'm gonna be his daddy
[Music]
oh shake shake
mr peters that is not a good look for
the folks over at ea what do you think
they're gonna give you for that one man
the 10 points whatever
well let's pick up the spare on this
next one
wow it's too bad we're not testing hangs
just a little bit inside that looked
pretty though yeah
last one i'm gonna get it in the yellow
for sure oh bad snap
oh it's way far away
but we ain't hold on we have to fight
though
yeah it's at the five i take all the
points though well listen man the good
news is your kick accuracy rating is
already so low that to be honest man you
can only go up
you feel me yeah man i'm feeling good
about your chances right now
the best thing though what i'm good at
though is the next one i think
and that's catching so that's easy my
only question is
is there anybody there that can throw a
football for us yeah
hell yeah for sure i got cuz wait who's
cuz oh it's my big cousin josh johnson
man you know
played for the all 32 teams in the
league
obama's still good but yeah josh what
kind of hands does marcus have in terms
of quarters
i wasn't comparing the corners because
they can't catch he got receiver hands
now marcus speaking of hands you have to
see
how your madden character fairs with a
few passes and i got to admit
they got you messed up bro
yeah that's disrespectful and the
receiver still catches it
that does not happen in real life let's
add a db back pedal
i want you to break on the ball because
i'm thinking if we show
madden about your catching skills doing
this
it won't even be a question let's do it
there is
pressure and i love it
[Music]
oh oh man what happened there
it was a bad jump timing by me
timing is everything all right what's on
deck we're gonna dig
see this is what marcus does breaking on
balls
[Music]
this is his specialty making that jump
all right marcus we got to wake it up
for this last one what do you got for me
so look when you do that i pick this
right off against the rams
so all i'm gonna do is just get my ass
to the sideline
and play and then high point this is
what you were made for man this is your
route
[Music]
there go hey
show them how to do it marcus peters
i don't know about you but i feel really
good about today
so i'm gonna be the plug i'm gonna take
this tape to the adjuster
but i want you on that call with me okay
so pick up when i hit you up later all
right
for sure but yeah man thank you for
everything bro like i say
i'm a fan of maddie and i'm not gonna
complain about nothing that
for me that i haven't earned so it's all
good
my man marcus talks to talk he walks the
walk clint
what did you think of the video it's a
great video first of all kudos to you
and your team
very creative bringing back some old
school madden mechanics
showed some serious skills even some we
didn't even know we had
all right we're getting him on the call
because i need you to give the ratings
to his face so let's call marcus
hey what's going on with y'all man how
y'all doing big dog
marcus clint was popping man hopefully
we doing a good job over there adjusting
my [ __ ]
hey marcus good to talk to you man
thanks
all right give us the goods let's start
off with punting first
there's bonus ratings here so we're
going to start with kick accuracy
uh currently marx is a 14. um we're
actually going to bump him up
13 points to a 27 that makes him the
ninth best
corner in the nfl in kick accuracy now
that
doesn't stop there also saw some kick
power he was booming
moving up from a 15 rating to
27 plus 12 points now the 18th
best cornerback in kick power
all right now catching is the big one
because i know that marcos was already
we're battling for that number one spot
for catching
yeah marcus was already tied at number
one among corners with a catch rating of
81. he was typed with richard sherman
and patrick peterson
he is going to go up one point to an 82
and now is the
highest rated catching cornerback in
madden
oh that leads us to one question clint
and i need an answer with marcus peters
on the line
is marcus peters underrated
yes marcus peters is underrated bang
i salute everybody who out there who's
doing their thing on the defensive back
end but you feel me
hey man keep up man your boy out here
setting pace that y'all ain't really
[ __ ] with
i love it i love the honesty i love that
clint said on tape that marcus peters is
underrated
and i love that marcus now has the best
hands for any corner
in the nfl that is underrated i am adam
lefkow
big shout out to the big dude marcus
peters for making it happen
and a shout out to state farm for their
surprisingly great rates
for making this episode possible thank
you for watching
[Music]
you like what you just saw subscribe to
bleacher report on youtube for more
underrated